photography feasible under people
uh this is going to be pretty informal
uh thanks Robert for also using the
board and not making me feel like I'm
the only one who didn't prepare slides
and everything
um so yeah I'm interested in uh the
foundations of cryptography more
generally but today I guess I'll briefly
talk about
um some a theme I guess in some of my
work which is trying to understand
uh what you can do as a cryptographer
if uh let me find marker
if uh P equals NV
yeah
can
we do crypto
if P equals NP
so right uh in uh the answer is sort of
no under classical uh rights definitions
right one-way functions don't exist in
some sense one-way functions or some
very rigorous sense one-way functions
are minimal uh for all of cryptography
uh but the but maybe there's something
there's something interesting that can
be done even if P equals NP so today I'm
just going to talk about two specific
sort of uh lines of work which at least
seem to be independent of P versus NP
um you can hope to get some sort of
security guarantees
uh so one is easy to Define and motivate
um and easy to describe the results
because basically we don't know anything
about it but uh let's say I'll start
with that because it's easy and then
I'll talk about something that's more
complex and difficult to Define and
motivate so we know understand a lot
better
so the first
topic that I want to speak about is a
fine-grained cryptography
foreign
[Music]
or maybe not the most but something
something that we're interested in
so right you're all familiar I assume at
least those from the mcsp
The Meta complexity program are familiar
with the notion of a one-way function so
right the one-way function it's easy to
give an an input X it's easy to compute
f of x
but it's hard to to invert that right
it's hard to recover X
from f of x
okay
uh so what is is right this is a one-way
function
and it's a one-way function right what
is a fine-grained one-way function
it's exactly the same except we're going
to be more careful about what we mean by
easy and hard so easy here will mean say
for example it's computable in
essentially linear time it's easy to
compute f of x very easy to compute F
next and hard as opposed to most
traditional cryptography hard means hard
for any probabilistic polynomial time
adversary hard here we just say want to
say okay like is it hard for anyone
running in say quadratic time
okay
so as far as we know right it could be
that P equals NT but your fastest set
solver runs in N to the 1000th time and
then there's no obvious contradictions
here it's totally possible with such an
object could still exist
um and the hope is that because it's
independent of P versus NP and this is
sort of why we started looking at this
that maybe you can prove more
interesting things the sad story is that
uh
we haven't been able to sort of prove
the right any one-way function is
inherently a fine-grained one-way
function because it's just even harder
well I guess if it's very easy to
compute but you can do sort of
complexity leveraging to make it easy to
compute
and it will be extremely hard but we're
hoping to get sort of more natural
candidates but still it's been I guess
six years now or something like this and
we're still not here there's sort of
natural problems that you can conjecture
are fine-grained one-way functions but
sort of now these conjectures aren't
very interesting you can take a problem
like planted cake leak or something and
you can say like right this basically is
a one-way function or planted case um
I'm not going to just find these
problems but there are these natural
sort of problems algorithmic problems
that very naturally lead to these
objects but somehow it's not there's no
Theory there that's that's particularly
interesting there's other Notions of
fine-grained cryptography however and
there's here the the connections get
more interesting but yeah I'd be very
interested perhaps this semester
uh maybe they're sort of we can come up
with sort of a more General treatment of
these kinds of objects right
I mean I don't see exactly how you would
connect it to Como Grove complexity
given that there's like this tight
fine-grained aspect but I'd be happy to
explore this okay so this is the first
one easy to Define and describe because
there's really not a lot to say uh the
second object I'd like to introduce
is a something called a non-notible code
so uh this is uh something that came out
of uh temper resilience and cryptography
uh maybe the motivations are slightly
less clear I'm not going to talk about
so much about the original motivations
for this object but I'll try to instead
I think I think it's a very interesting
object it's very I try to at least
describe to you what it is
um so okay so in a traditional sort of
coding setting uh right you want to send
a message through a channel
right in the error correcting codes you
want to recover right you're going to
encode your message
and you want to decode it an error
correction you want to recover the
original message
right error correction becomes
impossible if the channel can change all
of the bits right so if we can call this
as a code word
right if the channel can just delete the
code word and write some new code word c
Prime you'll get out some y Prime and
there's really there's some why this
that's not necessarily X and there's
really no hope of doing any error
correction
so what is a non-maluable code what you
should think of it a non-maluable code
as the guarantee we give up on
recovering the message that you
originally sent
and instead we have this guarantee that
basically this kind of attack where you
just completely delete what happened
before
is the only thing that the channel can
do
on the the entire experiment
let me so let me describe this
uh a little bit more in depth so in
particular
right so we have a non-viable code
you have some some Channel let's call it
f
which is going to be in some class
capital f
adversarially chosen
you're going to perform this experiment
to get out some some yeah expat or
something what we want
informally the guarantee to be here is
that either X hat is
exactly the same as what you started
with
or it's independent
of x
or I should mention that in this setting
it's inherent that you have a randomness
this is Randy these are randomized
randomized procedures
okay independent of X and I also right
additionally we wanted which case you're
in is also independent to mix right you
shouldn't be like tampering to bot right
and this this camper this is supposed to
capture a notion of temper resilience
right in particular suppose X is like a
number like 10 right you shouldn't we
want Tempo resilience we don't want you
to be able to produce a related encoding
so right we shouldn't be able to add one
given ten I get 11. given 13 given get
14.
right this came out of some attacks on
signature schemes and cryptography
there's this certain algebraic attacks
where they were able to extract keys but
that's not super super important
so you want stamp resilience and write
this notion right either you get back
exactly what was there right you get the
key that you have in your crypto system
doesn't change if x is a key or it's
just like completely random garbage that
has nothing to do with what you started
with
okay
so this is sort of the informal
definition of a non-maluable code one
way that you can formalize this that I
think is uh compelling
as you can say right that for all f any
function in this class of sort of
channels that you want to build your
non-maluable code against
this whole experiment
should be closed to
some distribution
it can depend on this file function so
there exists some GF a distribution
over
is the identity function
and
any
constant
function
so if you have some distribution GF such
that this whole experiment where I
encode tamper decode it's close to some
distribution that's either just right I
just randomly sample I flipped some
coins and I either sample the identity
function or a sample write a constant
function the constant function is right
you should think of is This experiment
right with this example where you just
delete what's on the channel and put
something at your favorite code word in
its place
okay why is this interesting I think uh
from a complexity standpoint is because
right what are what we're trying to do
here is we're trying to take some
channel f which you might think of as
very uh inherently complex maybe right
some this is a poly-sized circuit or
something like this an N squared side
circuit or you don't know what it is but
some arbitrary ends right N squared
circuit and we're transforming it into
something
thank you
by wrapping it and encoding and decoding
into something that's incredibly simple
right it either does nothing it's the
identity function or deletes it and
replaces it with a constant
and I think there's like an obvious a
parallel I don't know I'm almost out of
time but I'd like to sort of set up a
parallel there's a parallel here to uh
for example like I think it's helpful
to think about say for example uh this
hassad switching Lemma in this context
that's right and start switching Lemma
says that if I take an ac0 circuit and I
compose it with a random restriction
then the result
is much much simpler than this ac0
circuit right it's just this low depth
decision tree
right I can collapse it
true to uh to a decision tree
with another code we're getting where
you have a similar similar sort of
collapse so we have a number of results
that sort of make some sort of
connection between circuit lower bounds
and non-maluable codes and temporal
resilience and more explicit so in
particular using techniques from certain
circuit lower bounds for example we can
show unconditionally that there exists
codes where f is AC zero circuit or
right of local circuit which I guess is
a subclass
or for example and under so if you're
willing to assume strong circuit lower
bounds
should the randomization style
assumptions we can show that you can
build these objects even for like
polycyte circuits
and circuit lower bounds are inherent
here right this decoding function is a
hard to compute function it's actually
so an explicit non-maluable code gives
you explicit circuit lower bounds the
decode is hard to compute for the
function class and it's on average case
hardness results right you can the
encoding function will give you a
district an explicit distribution
that is hard to compute the deal
that's what I have to say
any questions
yeah Lexi Laura balance you need to do
this for like people they hold if P
equals MP they hold
they so they say basically
uh that it's it's so it's explicitly
what it is is key is hard for
exponential size non-deterministic
circuits so in some sense it's saying
that non-determinism doesn't help too
much instead of saying right
and can you also build these objects
from like the standard type of crypto
library of assumptions or is it oh No
actually that's a great question so we
have other work that uses
the crypto assumptions to build yeah
where this so here for this like right
the the circular bound result this is a
statistical better closeness in the
right if you use crypto it's sort of
you're almost inherently getting
computational closeness it's hard for
efficient distinguishers to tell which
world you're living in uh and even then
know these aren't completely we don't
know how to do it from standard objects
they tend to be uh they with the all of
our constructions that we know involve
things that we don't know how to
explicitly instantiate so it the sort of
uniform hash functions that we don't
know how to build from standard
assumptions you know like a random
Oracle is good but
in some sense this doesn't give you an
explicit code which is somewhat problem
okay maybe take the question offline
okay
okay let's um
more on to the final Talk of the make
the film